reaches up for the rebound paces up
fancy pass and it's down how about again
Ben Simmons showing it behind the back
you're just born with it's the sixth
sense to shooter most of the time but
not tonight Ben Simmons some of that
pretentious Talent line them up get to
the rim draw the foul and finish with
the OP control five on five scrimmages
all right the Commissioner will be
speaking when that happens we will take
you to it
[Applause]
never looks at him and that's what makes
that play works a lot of times in the
defenders you're looking at the eyes of
the offensive player his hand on that
and just that quickly gave it up Simmons
behind the back he's got company if it's
key back and slamming in the face of the
future hall-of-famer is Ben Simmons take
a look at it in transition coming right
at you Ben coast-to-coast to five come
fake finish Big Ben
not a lot of fun yeah not a lot of fun
at all especially if you're not in the
offensive estate
Ben Simmons throwing it down yet another
dump for him there's five of them and I
wonder which one we're going to show you
all the latest there it is the nice
extension and emphatic follow TJ
probings good ball movement and beard on
the other end good spacing for the sixes
battles walk whoo
Simmons some
[Music]
marvelous play by Ben Simmons field look
at this right here
Oh going one way can lose his cast meet
in the sweet vigor old qasimi's out of
your picture steal moments image turning
garbage into sparkling gold
[Applause]
JJ's off the curl
man nobody blocking him out gotta
believe it starts off as getting the
rebound and then Hey
we did Ben Simmons was out here just
putting on a clinic with the basketball
and won and how about this the Ron don't
ask behind the bat the Sixers aggressive
defensively and quite frankly the
Cavaliers out of sync
Simmons nicely done for Covington it'll
be a timeout Tehran Lou 12th lead change
of the night we've had 14 ties as well
Simmons all the way to the company throw
it down
[Applause]
it's like we've seen been effective in a
number of different ways how about the
nice little you love playing with guys
like that because those are the guys
that keep you out on the floor with the
victim yes a gorgeous look by Ben
Simmons especially the Grammys has
Huntington picked it clean and can he
get at the Simmons what a play by
Covington and sin enslaves for two going
to get it and they're off and running
Robert with the tip up ahead with the
finish but it all started with Dario
Felicio lost it we should stop dribbles
boy
Simmons delivering 2mb bluetooth on the
road and what I like is I figured out
what he's doing the before he's lighting
a match when he rubs his hand on the
floor that was some fire right there
game his intensity on D but on the
offensive end
what teammate to another two five with
the flush nice defense on him by Walker
six to try to squeeze off Walker they do
Simmons is going to sleep good here in
this quarter helping out defensively
throwing it down for to the Sixers now
leading by nine here at break Simmons
ten behind the back as we take a look at
the craft work of Ben Simmons all that
goes out there and he goes behind the
back sheds of both goes down lays it in
over Tatum 88 three-pointers in the
seven game series against Milwaukee 14
points here in Game one Redick gives it
back at Simmons with the left-handed
thrown out
[Applause]
six foot ten but his handle is
exceptional he gets that closed he can
score and he can score in bunches we
talked about again that Cavalier game
last year when he was in Cleveland Wow
then simmons finished the job
compliments a perk on court ma wendy's
seems likes that and the defender coming
over to interject looks like he got a
piece of it bends still able to catch it
yes there's the foul right move by
Plumlee he would not be at the top of a
list of offensive options but that was
well done Simmons in bucket look at this
a little mistake on the exchange and
Simmons just like Beasley thinks he's
just catch it and that puts Plumlee at a
deficit Dennis Evans says you just paid
a big-time mistake
he gets a lot of looks like that the
things we talked about what to watch
they're there for a reason i-70 was
found but wait to pass as well from it
be sporting the new headband
number 25 good mojo is al Jefferson was
the last Hornet to wear that number
[Applause]
[Music]
two for one opportunity for the matching
if they work at right Scott getting a
piece of the rock it triggers the Sixers
Milton for savings who throw it down
what a catch with one hand by Simonton
to the druggist blogging about
Richardson never hit a Livonia other
look at it as we take a look at shot
goes up it looks like it grazes the
right side of the rim hence making what
Ben does to follow completely legit yep
and that would tie the game
Simmons has Aaron Holliday now on a
switch
[Applause]
here he goes and he slams for two
Fitzsimmons first bucket of the third
corner that action again Holliday on him
defenders late to get there and look at
it again
Holliday underneath thought better of it
meaning he treats he has started
[Applause]